coucou comment ça va comment est-ce que
vous allez aujourd'hui alors regardez
aujourd'hui de quoi on parle on se parle
de ça on se parle de tout nouveau
produit tout nouveau produit qui était
présenté il y a pas très longtemps me
semble-t-il à New York par Bose et bien
ce sont les Coyotes confort hirbus 2 QC
Airbus 2 deuxième génération qui ne sont
selon Bose que la meilleure réduction de
bruit au monde écouteur et casque
confondus très jolie promesse donc on va
regarder ça je vais vous donner mon
retour on va regarder si ces écouteurs
sont vraiment intéressants on va
regarder quels sont les caractéristiques
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut pas faire à qui il se destine
quel est le tarif et puis au bout du
bout du bout parce que c'est
potentiellement ce qui nous intéresse
est-ce qu'il faut venir les acheter vous
êtes prêts on y va
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui
réalisait en partenariat avec la Fnac
pour venir vous présenter c'est tout
nouveau écouteurs de Bose c'est qui Bose
c'est tout simplement l'inventeur de la
réduction de bruit active rien que ça
une fois de plus donc en boost vous dit
si on a les meilleurs écouteurs avec une
réduction de bruit active globalement on
peut les croire alors vous allez voir
c'est très intéressant parce que ces
écouteurs moi je les trouve très cool
très cool pourquoi déjà j'aime bien le
design on a une forme de la couleur
c'est ce qu'on appellera le triple noir
parce qu'on appellera c'est-à-dire ce
que Bose a appelé le triple noir je
pense triple noir parce qu'en fait il va
y avoir trois finitions noirs le noir un
petit peu mate on va retrouver du noir
brillant ici voyez à l'intérieur et
peut-être aussi un petit peu de noir
qu'on va retrouver au niveau du silicone
allez savoir c'est peut-être ça c'est le
triple noir il existe également le saute
Stone qui est un blanc l'espèce de petit
galet blanc qui est aussi très sympa
personnellement je suis amoureux du noir
et je garde le noir alors je vais vous
montrer plusieurs choses ici au niveau
de ses écouteurs première chose c'est la
façon dont ils sont fabriqués à savoir
que vous allez retrouver sur le dessus
bien un écouteur avec un embout en
silicone vous avez une petite bande
alors le truc qui est très intéressant
ici c'est qu'en fait vous allez
plusieurs tailles regardez je vous
montre ça il faut aller fouiller un
petit peu dans la boîte ça c'est un truc
que nous a fait Bose et qui est
extrêmement malin je prends j'enlève les
fioritures et regardez ça ça c'est très
très cool pourquoi parce qu'en fait vous
avez trois tailles de bande celle qui
est installée c'est la taille numéro 1
c'est-à-dire c'est celle-là vous voyez
donc là elle est positionnée petite
bande classique mais si je veux
augmenter la taille de ma bande je peux
le faire je peux en mettre une beaucoup
plus grande qui va venir ici jouer le
maintien et ça peut être intéressant
notamment si vous allez faire du sport
si vous allez courir parce que vous
aurez un très bon maintien à vous de
voir en fonction de l'activité du moment
et puis l'autre truc qui est super cool
c'est qu'ici vous avez trois tailles
d'embout par défaut on a le médium plus
grand vous avez un plus petit et si on
se fait un multiple trois fois trois on
voit qu'on va jusqu'à 9 combinaisons
différentes donc ça va dépendre
totalement aussi de vos besoins de ce
que vous allez en faire donc moi comme
elle est là je trouve très bien pour
aller me balader en ville pour écouter
de la musique c'est super super chouette
le confort est très très bon ça c'est un
truc aussi très très fort parce que vous
prenez vous les mettez dedans et vous
venez légèrement twister vous venez
légèrement tourner le confort est super
cool et ça c'est un élément ça fait boum
c'est pas de sort orchestral qui vient
calibrer le son pour mon oreille d'un
côté hop là je mets l'autre enfin la
même chose de l'autre côté voilà je suis
parti comme ça je suis plutôt pas mal le
confort est très très bon là je suis en
mode aware je l'ai laissé comme ça la
dernière fois donc j'ai demandé vous
allez voir dans l'application pour faire
pas mal de petites choses j'ai demandé
que lorsque je l'ai redémarré et bien
qu'il me remette exactement la
configuration d'avant là c'est le mode
aware donc je suis ouvert je m'entends
je peux dire converser directement avec
vous ça c'est très très cool j'ai
l'impression de pas les avoir mis tout à
l'heure dans le train j'ai fait quoi
j'ai fait trois heures et demi de
pendant tout le temps je vous assure que
le confort est vraiment bon et qui sont
très agréable à porter
[Musique]
autre élément important on peut venir
courir alors vous voyez j'ai pas mis la
plus grosse aînette là je suis sur la
plus petite taille et si vous allez
courir alors j'ai pas vu jeter partout
mais en fait on a un très bon maintien
alors l'idée c'est pas d'aller
headbangué dans un festival de métal
soyons clair ici mais si vous allez
courir légèrement comme ça et que vous
avez pas pour autant envie de mettre la
plus grosse tête que vous avez pas envie
ou besoin de le changer ça conviendra
comme ça donc si vous allez faire du
sport dans une salle vous allez faire du
running vous allez faire du stepper vous
allez faire ce que vous voulez ça
conviendra parfaitement bien et l'autre
truc qui est très très chouette ça c'est
je pense notamment à mon beau-père par
exemple typiquement lui mon Nono
d'ailleurs je t'embrasse tu regardes
cette vidéo à droite il a du médium et à
gauche il a du Small parce qu'il a en
fait des conduit auditifs qui sont un
petit peu différents et bien on peut
venir ici choisir mettre du médium d'un
côté du Small ou du large en fonction de
l'oreille de chacun donc elle vient
complètement s'adapter à l'oreille de
chaque personne on peut personnaliser
l'expérience puisqu'on est au niveau de
la boîte on va y rester regardez je vais
vous montrer tac tac tac hop là elle est
là vous avez dans la boîte en plus ici
un petit câble de recharge en USBA et en
USB C de l'autre côté pour ça ça
conviendra parfaitement bien qu'on est
un peu l'histoire ça ça me va tout en
sachant que ici vous les recharger
uniquement en pas de recharge sans fil
donc si vous êtes absolument un
inconditionnel qu'il vous faut
absolument de la recherche sans fil
c'est peut-être pas celui-là qu'il vous
faut mais si vous voulez de la recharge
rapide de la recharge efficace en
filaire et bien en 20 minutes de charge
vous reprenez deux heures d'autonomie
donc vous êtes vraiment peinard tout en
sachant qu'ici vous avez jusqu'à 24
heures d'autonomie au total et jusqu'à
6h pardon ce qui globalement est très
bien alors il y a un autre truc que j'ai
noté et qui est vachement intéressant
c'est vraiment le retour d'expérience
que je vous fais là c'est à dire que ces
écouteurs je les ai pris dans
différentes configurations dans un
transport en commun je les prends à la
maison pour à côté de la musique je me
rase aussi des films je me regarde des
séries et lorsque je me baladais j'étais
dans un magasin tout à l'heure en train
d'acheter des trucs et lorsque vous les
avez avec votre réduction de bruit
active vous vous mettiez même le mode
aware vous les entendez s'adapter alors
c'est très très léger attention on n'a
pas un truc de fou mais on voit qu'ils
sont en train de s'adapter vous permet
d'avoir la meilleure expérience à un
instant T ça sa technologie qui
s'appelle custom tune elle va venir
détecter en fait comment votre canal
auditif transforme le son et elle va
venir s'ajuster en fonction de ça donc
on a un super confort ils sont
personnalisable mais qu'en est-il
maintenant de la qualité audio et ça
c'est aussi un truc qui m'a vachement
plus alors on le sait on connaît Bose
attention on connaît vraiment de la
qualité de Bose si vous connaissez
notamment le qc45 vous savez qu'on a des
super casques de très très bonne qualité
au niveau des écouteurs c'est la même
chose Bose ici est un maître l'audio et
une fois de plus il fait nous le montrer
le truc qui est intéressant ici c'est
qu'en fait lorsque je l'écoutais vous
voyez sur différents styles de musique
je vais retrouver des bases qui sont
profondes c'est à dire que lorsque je
vais écouter de la musique je sais pas
quel morceau je peux vous prendre par
exemple je me suis écouté un morceau
d'Aéro Smith le savez la BO d'Armageddon
et un moment quand ça commence à jouer
vous avez la base qui fait juste une
note
bon c'est pas la bonne note que je vous
fais là mais en fait vous voyez quand ça
commence et qu'on a la basse on l'entend
et on a cette rondeur en fait elle
l'ampli vraiment les écouteurs et ça
vous l'avez forcément quel que soit le
style de musique que vous allez écouter
ici autre truc que j'ai bien aimé il y a
un morceau j'écoute tout le temps
lorsque j'ai testé des casques sur
lequel je sais que je vais retrouver ici
une cymbale et si je retrouve pas ma
cymbale et bien je sais que il y a un
petit trou au niveau de mes aiguilles de
mes médium aigus ici j'ai ma cymbale est
très clair alors j'ai ma cymbale j'ai
pas que ma symbole je fais attention
aussi à mon Charleston est-ce que j'ai
un peu tous ces aiguilles tous ces
médiums aigus qui ont vraiment une très
belle clarté et je la retrouve ici donc
ça veut dire que déjà au niveau de mon
spectre c'est à dire mais grave de mes
médium grave j'ai de la présence j'ai de
la rondeur donc je vais jusqu'en bas au
niveau des fréquences mais je vais aussi
jusqu'en haut et l'autre truc qui est
bien c'est que les médiums je trouve
jolie on a de bons médium avec une belle
présence pareil un morceau que j'écoute
tout le temps parce que je viens tester
des casques ou des écouteurs et bien je
sais qu'au début monstre ça va commencer
j'ai vraiment un son de guitare qui
attaque et je retrouve un peu le mordant
vous voyez c'est pas si vous êtes gratos
je sais pas si vous parlera mais j'ai
vraiment le mordant de la guitare et
donc là j'en trouve donc en fait j'ai
vraiment cette espèce de trois grosses
familles de bandes fréquences et
vraiment histoire de simplifier
l'histoire au maximum avec mais grave de
la rondeur des aiguilles précis et des
médiums qui sont aussi très beaux et qui
me permet d'avoir un ensemble
extrêmement cohérent donc ça c'est chaud
donc j'ai une très très belle expérience
musicale donc ça c'est le premier truc
que je trouve vachement cool c'est super
important c'est la base c'est ce qu'on
attend ici d'écouteurs comme ça et puis
le deuxième point que je trouve aussi
super important et super impressionnant
c'est la réduction de bruit active là je
l'ai mis dans les oreilles alors j'ai
mis le mode transparent donc j'ai déjà
une réduction de bruit passive
c'est-à-dire que ça vient quand même
boucher les oreilles voyez mais comme
j'ai les micros qui vont injecter le son
de l'extérieur à l'intérieur de mes
haut-parleurs j'entends ce qui se passe
maintenant lorsque je viens laisser
appuyer ici je vais changer le mode
voilà la Coyote donc là j'ai tout coupé
donc là je m'entends parler mais
uniquement dans ma tête ça m'a coupé
l'extérieur donc on a une très bonne
réduction de bruit j'ai pris le train
tout à l'heure je vous dis j'ai fait
quoi 3h30 de train ça m'a quand même
vachement bien coupé donc c'est très
très cool stop on coupe on coupe je
voudrais qu'on prenne 2 secondes pour
parler de la réduction de bruit active
qu'est-ce que la réduction de bruit
active je sais pas si vous êtes familier
coutumier de ce terme-là c'est le fait
de venir annuler le son qui vient de
l'extérieur directement dans vos
oreilles les micro-ondes ont capté sont
l'extérieur ils vont faire une
soustraction par rapport au son qui
passe quand même dans votre oreille et
ensuite par un système de refasse ils
vont venir l'annuler ok c'est simple
c'est pratique c'est bien et ça marche
bien et ici comme je vous le disais tout
à l'heure Bose nous annonce tout
simplement avoir la meilleure réduction
de bruit active du marché écouteur et
casque confondu alors pour autant je
vais pas faire grand benchmark avec tous
les écouteurs du marché mais de mon
expérience personnelle et de ce que j'en
connais de ce que j'ai écouté je trouve
ça extrêmement efficace ça marche
vachement bien que ce soit dans les
graves les graves ça voulait supprimer
ça vous les coupe souvent le petit
résidu et ce qui reste c'est du médium
médium médium aigu si vous avez pris un
avion par exemple vous savez quand vous
avez au début les annonces de sécurité
vous les demander encore avec votre
casque Ellias et ses fréquences là qui
restent sont toujours un petit peu
résiduelles qui sont plus compliqués à
être filtrés ici par un casque ou par
des écouteurs alors pour autant ici il y
a une amélioration c'est bien meilleur
que ce qu'on avait sur la génération
précédente on sent qu'on est aussi une
réduction de bruit qui est bien
améliorée au niveau des médiums et que
je trouve extrêmement précis moi
personnellement lorsque j'utilise par
exemple des écouteurs comme cela et bien
ce que je fais en général je les mets
avec de la réduction de bruit et
j'écoute pas de musique ça m'arrive de
temps en temps sur des longs voyages
t'écoutais un peu de musique et la
plupart du temps c'est pour me couper et
pour être moins fatigué parce que tout
ce bruit dans un trajet dans un
transport je pense notamment si vous
prenez le train si vous prenez un avion
c'est extrêmement fatigant ici plus
besoin j'ai qu'à mettre mes écouteurs et
je suis peinard donc pour moi ici les
résultats il est bluffant Bose à très
très bien travaillé il continue
d'améliorer sa réduction de bruit et il
est vrai que avec ces Bose QC hirbuzz 2
et bien on a une excellente réduction de
bruit et on peut totalement venir la
comparer ici à la réduction de bruit
qu'on a sur des casques je trouve ça
extrêmement bluffant et une fois de plus
Bose à très bien bossé maintenant je
voudrais qu'on parle un peu de
l'application c'est Bose musique dans
Bose musique je retrouve ici mes boss QC
Airbus 2 j'ai mon qc45 mais n'est pas
connecté qui est à l'étage donc ça c'est
plutôt bien je vois mes niveaux de
batterie je suis connecté ok j'ai plus
qu'à y aller ici j'ai retrouvé
sensiblement la même chose à savoir bon
mes écouteurs sympas mon niveau de
batterie mon volume que je peux venir
moduler ici directement avec mon doigt
ça c'est plutôt cool vous voyez je
m'écoutais tout à l'heure un morceau de
Lady Gaga comme ça vous savez tout vous
voyez exactement ce que j'écoutais tout
à l'heure je vais avoir différents modes
alors les différents modes ils sont
assez marrants parce qu'en fait
normalement lorsque vous le prenez
lorsque vous avez une configuration
d'usine vous avez deux modes soit le
mode silence soit le mode attentif le
mode silence est réduction de bruit à
fond clairement le mode attentif c'est
on vient prendre le son extérieur on
l’injecte comme j'ai fait tout à l'heure
pour permettre de discuter d'être
attentif à son environnement mais vous
pouvez venir rajouter des modes et les
créer moi j'ai créé le mode transport et
j'ai créé le mode marche donc je peux
venir switcher comme ça très très
facilement de la même manière je viens
switcher en appuyant laissant en
appuyant sur mes écouteurs je vais vous
montrer comment je l'ai configuré ici
directement dans mon application autant
en mode silence je peux pas venir faire
grand chose autant le mode attentif je
peux venir paramétrer j'appuie là vous
voyez typiquement je viens activer
actifense il vous le marque hein si les
bruits extérieurs sont trop gênants Bose
règle automatiquement le niveau de
réduction de bruit ambiant afin que vous
puissiez écouter confortablement votre
musique ça c'est automatique ça c'est
vachement intelligent c'est très bien et
après vous choisissez moi par exemple
dans les transports je dis bah je vais
être complètement fermé vous voyez
j'appuie là réduction de bruit dans les
transports je choisis quel niveau de
réduction de bruit je veux en fonction
si je suis dans le métro et que je veux
entendre par exemple vous arrivez à tel
arrêt tel arrêté l'arrêt ou dans le bus
ou peu importe et bien hop là bon ben je
me laisse quand même passer un petit peu
de son ou alors je veux complètement
fermer je peux fermer je choisis et je
viens complètement le personnaliser et
vous avez compris l'histoire c'est la
même chose pour tout pour le mode marche
c'est la même chose j'appuie là dans la
rue je veux quand même me faire un peu
mais je veux entendre ce qui se passe
quand même donc je viens choisir et je
viens tout customiser et si vous
regardez il vous le Mac vous disposez de
quatre modes maximum j'en ai mis 4 mais
si vous vouliez elle est renommée
autrement vous pourriez vous n'auriez
qu'à appuyer ici et vous choisissez le
mode marche accueil concentration course
extérieur musique relax sport transport
travail il y en a plein et ça c'est très
très malin donc à vous de voir quels
sont les modes qui sont les plus
pertinents par rapport à vos usages mais
ça une fois de plus dans l'application
c'est très très cool autre élément
choisissez votre source alors ici moi
j'ai mis un iPhone mais vous pouvez
mettre ce que vous voulez en ressource
pour lequel vous allez venir connecter
si vous écouteurs en Bluetooth 5.3 s'il
vous plaît un petit équaliseur alors
l'équaliseur ici c'est vraiment histoire
de se marrer j'ai connu des écouteurs
qui ait des équaliseurs un petit peu
plus complets ici vous avez juste trois
bandes vous choisissez vos graves vos
médiums vos aigus c'est pas la meilleure
expérience au niveau des équaliseurs
néanmoins vous pouvez venir un peu les
paramétrer moins je les écoute flat il y
en a certains c'est quoi les heures où
j'aime bien venir un petit peu voyez des
fois rajouter un peu de graves un peu
dégueu casse un peu les médiums ici je
laisse flat parce que je trouve que le
son comme il est choisi ici par Bose il
marche vraiment bien après vous avez
quatre modes qui vous sont proposés
voyez vous choisissez faites ce que vous
voulez après vous réinitialisez vous
mettez là vous pouvez venir le module et
vous directement vous partez de -10
jusqu'à + 10 c'est vous qui choisissez
bon ok moi je laisse flat après vous
avez des petits raccourcis alors c'est
là où ça devient intéressant parce que
de base je vous l'ai dit vous avez vos
petits clics une fois play une fois pose
morceau suivant trois fois morceau
précédent vous laissez un appui long
cherchant trop les modes et justement on
peut venir choisir c'est à dire que moi
sur mon écouteur droit vous le voyez à
cause de droit je l'ai activé et là j'ai
mis parcourir les modes donc je viens
switcher entre mes différents modes et
sur l'écouteur gauche à contrario j'ai
fait quelque chose de différent j'ai
choisi de mettre mon assistant vocal
donc lorsque je viens laisser appuyer à
gauche j'appelle mon assistant vocal et
ça c'est plutôt malin alors je peux
choisir de le mettre ou de ne pas le
mettre de faire comme je veux ou de
mettre les deux du même côté ou de
mettre la même chose à droite et à
gauche donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal tout
en sachant que par défaut vous avez
Lecture pause morceau suivant morceau
précédent décrocher raccrocher et puis
ensuite vous avez quelques petits
conseils si vous avez besoin de conseils
pour l'assistant vocal la commande
tactile les appels téléphoniques
réduction de bruit et les différents
modes et puis sur la charge ok c'est
très très simple tout en sachant que
vous avez plein d'autres paramètres ici
bon le nom du produit les conseils on
les a vu il y a beaucoup de choses qui
se recoupent en fait si vous voulez test
d'ajustement des embouts pouvez venir
faire ici si vous le souhaitez bande de
stabilité donc il vous explique un peu
vos bandes comment ça marche aussi et ça
comment décoller la bande actuelle
comment enfiler la nouvelle bande bon
voilà c'est des petits tutos en fait on
vient vraiment vous aider et vous
expliquer comment ça marche connexion
Bluetooth contrôle du produit donc vos
raccourcis sont on l'a vu tout à l'heure
je vous l'ai montré ce petit mode là le
son les différents modes qu'on va avoir
ça c'est un truc qui est pas mal c'est
mémoriser vos modes une fois que vous
avez enlevé vos écouteurs il va
mémoriser le mode donc si vous arrêtez
en mode marge vous la mettez vous êtes
en mode marche si vous les avez enlevés
en mode ambiant vous serez en mode
ambiant c'est pareil c'est un petit truc
tout bête à faire mais il faut venir
activer je trouve ça très très chouette
légaliseur vous allez retrouver ici bon
ok c'est exactement la même chose et
puis ensuite préférence au niveau de la
voie alors vos appels téléphoniques
préférence de votre propre voix
attention au cours de l'appel
téléphonique élevé moyen faible ou
carrément désactivé détection
intra-auriculaire lecture posé compagnon
vous voyez quelques petits modes qui
sont là qui sont assez pratiques un
guide vocal collection et appelle niveau
de batterie au démarrage la langue alors
là moi je l'ai mis en anglais maintenant
vous avez raison je vais mettre en
français soit que j'ai l'habitude en
anglais donc ça me dérange pas hop là je
choisis ma langue je le mets en français
c'est plutôt cool caractéristiques
techniques question courante donc vous
voyez j'ai tout dans mon application ici
directement donc il y a rien de bien
sorcier l'application est là avec des
fonctionnalités de base c'est peut-être
pas là où on aura le plus de choses il y
a certains autres constructeurs qui vont
en mettre des tonnes mais pour autant ce
qu'on a ici fonctionne bien alors après
pour parler un peu techno juste pour
être dans la techno il faut savoir
qu'ici et bien vous avez 4 micros par
écouteur ce qui vous permet de
totalement optimiser cette réduction de
bruit la réduction de bruit repose sur
le fait d'annuler le son qui vient de
l'extérieur donc vous avez des micros
qui vont capter le son qui vient de
l'extérieur ensuite vous avez des micro
à l'intérieur qui vont venir analyser le
son qui arrive à l’intérieur de votre
oreille une fois que vous avez bien
positionné si votre petit écouteur il va
faire un petit calcul ensuite il va
prendre le son que vous à l'extérieur le
son qui est à l'intérieur de votre
oreille pour qui vient de l'extérieur il
va venir supprimer le son qui passe pour
venir vous isoler si c'est ce que vous
souhaitez c'est ce qu'on appelle la
réduction de bruit active c'est un
système de HORSE phase en fait bon bref
peu importe passera rapidement là-dessus
et ici Bose le fait avec pas moins de 4
micros par écouteurs tout en sachant
qu'ici vous avez la puce Qualcom S5
audio SOC au niveau des codes qu'on a de
SBC et Dua AC ici il y a pas d'appétit x
c'est marrant parce que on a quand même
la puce walcomm ici mais non pas de
codec welcome pas d'appétit X et dernier
point un peu technique on a les
écouteurs qui sont certifiés IP X4 donc
résistant à la transpiration et à l'eau
bon pour autant n'allez pas nager dans
la piscine avec ça pas fait pour et ils
sont disponibles au tarif de
299 euros 95 c'est un certain prix
certes et à ce prix là vous avez ce que
aujourd'hui Bose vous propose de mieux
histoire connaître que franchement je
les aime bien je les ai trouvés super
intéressant je vous dis dans différents
cas de figure dans la rue que ce soit
dans les transports en commun que ce
soit à la maison le confort est là la
personnalisation est là on vient
vraiment choisir en fonction des usages
en fonction de ce qu'on veut faire la
commande tactile très facile à venir
utiliser baisser le son monter le son
voyant avec la glisser notre doigt comme
ça c'est très très cool play pause voilà
donc ça c'est assez marrant et ça ça
marche bien donc je les aime bien je
trouve intéressant et le fait qu'ils
viennent s'adapter en permanence pour
vous délivrer la meilleure expérience au
niveau de la réduction de bruit et
forcément au niveau de la qualité audio
et bien je trouve ça très très cool donc
à vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez comment vous les trouvez c'est
quoi YouTube confort irbuzz 2 est-ce
qu'il vous plaise ou non est-ce qu'il
pourrait vous tenter oui non marquer le
moi juste en bas dans les commentaires
et puis si vous intéresse bien
évidemment je vous ai mis un lien juste
en bas allez-y pour y cliquez merci à
vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez juste en
bas dans les commentaires et puis je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt les bisous d'amour Ciao
[Musique]